By the time of the late 1990s, the days of
the traveling salesman were on the gradual
decline.
More and more consumers out there were being
all too easily enticed by the alluring draw
of advertisements broadcast directly into
their homes through their television sets,
or beamed out over the radio between the latest
chart hits.
Hell, even catalogs sent straight to people’s
mailboxes were making it all the harder for
the door to door industry to stay afloat.
Times, they were a-changing, and everyday
working people were no longer content to allow
a total stranger to stand on their front porch
and peddle their wares at them.
Jerry had been at that game for almost twenty
years now.
He had been born with a natural gift of the
gab that made him a real savant of sales,
a Michelangelo of making people part with
their hard-earned money, a Da Vinci of discounts
and dealing, if you will.
Okay, I’ll stop now.
Sorry.
His fellow salesmen on the road sometimes
called him ‘Mr Motor Mouth’ - Not to be
confused with SCP-2094.
They used to joke that Jerry could talk his
way out of a sealed room with no doors or
windows, while also convincing said room pay
him an exit fee as well.
But, as much as he had a knack for making
deals, he had felt the tides shifting lately.
The business of driving across the country
to sell products direct to customers was fast
becoming a thing of the past, an almost arcane
practise in the age of the infomercial and
the catchy jingles of advertisements.
Companies were growing, becoming far bigger,
absorbing one another to the point where they
were conglomerates, corporations that could
form entire departments dedicated to marketing
campaigns for their various products.
They no longer needed the work of men on the
ground, talking face to face with consumers.
Even the smaller companies were giving up
on that method of marketing, choosing instead
to sell their patents and products to the
big boys in exchange for a hefty sum.
His job as a door to door salesman was on
its way to an inevitable grave, and Jerry
knew it.
With the looming threat of occupational redundancy
on the horizon, he had decided that it was
time to cash out, to give up a life on the
road and either find a new job somewhere,
or face the prospect of going flat broke.
But it was hard to leave the scene if you
didn’t have the green.
Between the expenses of keeping his car in
tip top shape to take him from state to state,
and the ever increasing cut his marketing
agency took out of his earnings, Jerry needed
to see out just one more quarter.
It wouldn’t be too hard, he thought to himself,
not for old Mr Jerry Motor Mouth.
Little did he know, the sales game had a new
player on the board, one whose powers of persuasion
were far greater than Jerry ever could have
imagined…
A small company that sold its own brand of
food processors had employed the sales agency
that he worked for.
And, seeing as Jerry was one of the few old
guard, classic door to door salesmen that
hadn’t been laid off or let go – yet – he
was off on the open road for what he hoped
would be the final time.
His windows down, the sweet, timely sounds
of R.E.M.
blasting on his radio, Jerry drove into the
next town on his list.
The last ten places he had stopped in had
all been a nightmare for shifting units, meaning
he still had boxes upon boxes of stock to
shift.
Currently, said cardboard boxes were cramping
up the backseats of his car, with more threatening
to burst from the trunk and the towbar cargo
box affixed to the rear bumper of his old
Plymouth Utility.
But it seemed like no matter what city, town
or suburb he arrived at, with his car full
of food processors to sell, Jerry kept finding
that he had arrived only too late.
“Oh, no thanks,” the homeowners he visited
would say.
“I just bought a new food processor, the
ad on TV just really sold it to me.”
Everywhere he turned, every door that he rapped
his knuckles on, all brought the same answer
with it.
Naturally, eleven locations in and barely
more than a few units sold, Jerry was starting
to worry his magic motor mouth had run out
of steam.
Had he really lost his knack?
Or was this rival food processor manufacturer
simply pilfering all his potential customers
through their ad campaign?
After another unsuccessful day, those were
the only questions spinning around and around
in Jerry’s head as he paced back and forth
in the motel room he was staying in.
The TV was on, playing an ad break between
a rerun of an episode of Seinfeld, just proving
some light background noise…
although it would soon present the answer
to Jerry’s questions.
The chime of a catchy, cheesy jingle caught
his attention first, followed by the name
of the company.
It was the same name Jerry had heard from
the lips of every home he’d stopped at.
This was the commercial that convinced them
all to buy this company’s food processor
over the ones he was trying to sell.
Grabbing the remote, Jerry jabbed the button
that increased the volume; he had to see how
they did it.
A large man, considerably overweight by some
people’s standards, appeared on screen and
started rattling off all sorts of details
about the rival company’s food processor.
At first, Jerry couldn’t help glaring at
the man, like they were bitter, lifelong enemies.
After all, it was because of this ad that
he was missing out on potential sales, and
risking not meeting his final quarterly quota.
But the more he watched the weighty man on
the screen, telling the viewer how wonderful
this product was, it was like Jerry could
feel a tiny part of himself agreeing.
Every word made sense somehow, like it was
just right, unequivocally, unquestionably,
categorically correct in every way.
He couldn’t refute that this other food
processor, despite being sold by his client’s
competition, did seem like the superior product.
“And if any of you folks need to be persuaded
further, then believe me when I tell you this,”
the man declared with a wide smile on his
red, sweat sheened face.
“You need this product in your life.”
He couldn’t argue with that, Jerry thought
to himself; he really did need one of those
food processors.
It wasn’t an all consuming, uncontrollable
need – at least, not yet – but more of
a gentle compulsion that became logged at
the back of his mind.
Something about the man’s words had him
pretty convinced, and he had to recognize
and even respect a fellow Salvador Dali of
the salesman’s craft.
His demeanour wasn’t exactly what you might
expect to see from someone presenting an ad,
there was no cheesy, jovial banter and forced,
false laughter.
In fact, the man had been pretty abrasive,
practically demanding the viewer to buy that
particular brand of food processor.
And yet, somehow, it seemed to leave a lasting
– albeit fleeting – impression on Jerry…
an impression that would only get worse the
next day.
He had decided to change his sales tactic,
drawing on an old trick from his two decades
of experience.
After barely selling any of his stock to homeowners,
Jerry figured his next best move was to try
his luck at local restaurants, cafes, and
any other type of business that might have
need of a new food processor.
Maybe, he thought to himself, if he was extremely
lucky, he could sell multiple units of stock
to each business he visited, making up for
the lack of sales he’d made so far.
But it was while driving through the center
of town that something caught Jerry’s eye.
It was magnetic, like a moth being drawn to
the bright glare of a lightbulb.
It was one of the food processors from the
advert, the same ones that everyone Jerry
had visited had already bought.
There it sat in a storefront window, as if
it was practically beckoning him inside.
The man on TV had told Jerry he needed one
for himself, and now that he could see it
as clear as day, he knew that was true.
For the next few minutes, it was like Jerry’s
brain had been set to autopilot mode.
He parked his car, turned the engine off,
opened the door and started walking towards
the store without stopping to think about
it at all.
Within minutes, he was not only inside, but
lifting a heavy box off the shelf and carrying
the shiny new food processor – the ones
sold by a company that were rivals to his
very own clients – up to the cashier.
Still not pausing to even consider what he
was doing, as if he had been put in a trance,
Jerry opened up his wallet and parted with
his hard earned cash, paying for the processor
and carrying it back to his car.
It wasn’t until he sat back down in the
driver’s seat, that Jerry seemed to wake
up, only to look in horror at the box he had
just placed in the seat next to him.
He blinked, his face awash with disbelief.
Never in all his years had he ever needed
something like a food processor, he had no
use for it.
But now he had just gone and absentmindedly
purchased one, from a rival brand no less…
and it had all been because that man on the
TV had told him he needed to.
He couldn’t go back to making sales that
day, how could he?
Even if he could get any of the town’s local
restaurants interested in buying the food
processors he had to sell, they would immediately
lose all faith in the product the minute they
spotted a different brand of the same device
sitting pristine in Jerry’s car.
Driving back to the motel, he just spent a
few hours sitting on the uncomfortable bed,
staring blankly in awe at what he had bought.
Overcome with a sudden rush of anger, although
mainly directed at himself, he hurled the
box across the room.
It banged loudly against the wall, then clattered
to the floor.
But it was just as he marched over to it,
about to stomp on the food processor with
his foot, that Jerry spotted something printed
on the back.
It was hidden among all the usual legal speak
that companies were required to have on their
products: ‘Not satisfied with this product?
Call our Customer Service hotline!’.
It was those few simple words, and the string
of numbers that followed it, that gave Jerry
an idea.
That man on the TV, someone at the rival company
must have hired him to present the advertisement.
And if he could find out who, and get in touch
with that oddly convincing man, that could
be the answer to his sales trouble…
little did Jerry expect that it would lead
to a whole different type of trouble for him.
It definitely didn’t come easy, starting
with a call to the company’s customer complaints
departments with the hope of being put through
to their advertising people was an uphill
challenge for anyone.
But Jerry wasn’t just anyone, he was Mr
Motor Mouth, the man who could talk his way
into and out of anything.
He knew he’d have to lie through his teeth,
or ‘bend the truth’ as he liked to call
it.
Each time he claimed to be from the Federal
Trade Commission or the United States Patent
and Trademark office, a cold tremble shuddered
through his hands, heart pounding faster against
his chest, icy sweat making his shirt stick
to his back.
Every lie was a risk, he could easily be reported
to the police for fraud.
But, by some miracle – or maybe a curse
– his phone call was passed from department
to department until he spoke to one of the
companies advertising personnel.
They were careless enough to give him the
address of the man who had been in their TV
ads... and it was only a short drive across
town.
Unlike earlier, Jerry was now fully aware
of what he was doing.
He just couldn’t believe he was actually
going through with it.
Standing outside the front door of the man
from the advertisement, the one who had seemingly
mesmerized him into buying something he didn’t
even need, he could feel his pulse beating
faster than ever.
Reaching out a shaking hand, he knocked loudly
on the door.
The sound of movement came from behind the
door, only for it to be pulled open.
There he was, standing in the doorframe.
Although he’d never say it out loud, Jerry
couldn’t help but wonder how such a large
man fit through his own doorway.
He somehow looked worse up close; the cameras
and makeup for the ad must have gone a long
way to mask just how very clear it was that
this man wasn’t exactly the model of perfect
health.
“Can I help you?” he asked abruptly.
“Y-yes, sorry,” Jerry stammered nervously.
“My name’s Jerry.
I saw you on a TV ad last night… for a food
processor.”
“I’m not giving out autographs.”
The man wasn’t just blunt, he was outright
impolite.
“Beat it, Jerry.”
“Wait!” he interjected, desperation making
his voice crack.
“Please, just let me explain.
I work in sales and I’ve got a car full
of similar products that I need to get people
to buy.”
“And you want me to help with that?”
the man predicted.
“Not interested.
I only do ads if I’m getting paid.”
By now, the sheer overwhelming nerves that
had taken hold of Jerry were quickly becoming
something else.
Hearing how bad-mannered and unaccommodating
this man was being made it hard to keep his
temper.
Frustration was boiling over into anger, and
eventually, it became too much to keep down
any longer.
Jerry reached too hands out to the man, gripping
his thick neck by the folds of his sweat-soaked
collar.
“Listen to me, you!” he said, his voice
raised as his rage came bursting out.
“I haven’t been able to sell one of these
damn things, and it’s all because of that
stupid ad you were in!
You even got me to buy one, I still have no
idea how!
I’m a door-to-door salesman for crying out
loud, what on earth would I ever want with
a food processor?
Tell me how you did it!”
“You want to take your hands off me, Jerry.”
The man’s voice was calm, almost unnerving
in how reserved he was being.
Before he had addressed Jerry dismissively,
but now he spoke with a collected, simplicity.
And it worked.
Somehow, it worked.
As if his arms were moving independently,
Jerry watched as his hands let go of the man’s
collar, staring wide-eyed.
He hadn’t wanted to take them away, hadn’t
made an effort to let go.
Except, the moment he was told that he wanted
to, he had wanted to, and loosened his grip
accordingly.
The man had told him what he wanted and somehow
made it true.
“Who… what are you?”
Jerry asked, looking up in horror at the larger
man.
“You want to not harm me,” the man replied
with that same, eerie calmness to his voice.
But there was something else there too, a
low tone of another, far crueler cadence.
“You want to hurt yourself though, Jerry.”
Something came speeding through the air and
caught the side of Jerry’s cheek.
The force of the object reeled him, causing
him to stagger back until he realized exactly
what had hit him: it was his own fist.
He’d punched himself… no, it was worse
than that.
He had wanted to harm himself, just like the
man had told him.
“I think what you really want,” the other
man continued, using a tone that now swam
with even more sadistic malice.
“Is to keep hitting yourself.”
The pain of another self-inflicted punch struck
Jerry, followed swiftly by a third.
His arms were moving impulsively, almost like
he had no control over them, but also as if
he couldn’t help but keep doing what this
man had said.
His fist clenched tight, an uppercut connected
with Jerry’s chin, causing one of his teeth
to chip against the other.
Spluttering, he spat out the fragment of enamel,
followed by a mouthful of blood and spittle.
“Let me make you an offer that you can’t
refuse,” the man announced.
“For the low, low price of nothing at all,
keep punching yourself in the face, as hard
as you can.
It’s the new best thing for you, right Jerry?
Don’t stop until you lose consciousness.”
Instantly, Jerry’s fists started pummelling,
striking one after the other.
The pain was pulsating through the skin of
his face, stinging under his eyes, reddening
and bruising every visible part.
Another hit connected sharply, and Jerry felt
the agony of his own nose breaking, the crunch
of bone as more blood spilled out of his nostrils,
wetting his mouth and staining it red.
The metallic tang of blood washed through
the back of his mouth as he knocked another
of his own teeth loose and accidentally swallowed
it, coughing and spraying more crimson bodily
fluid over his white work shirt.
It went on for hours.
By the time he had hit himself enough times,
Jerry’s face was completely unrecognizable.
His face was swollen, jaw dislocated, and
one eye so badly bruised that it had swollen,
practically shutting itself.
His arm raised once more of its own accord
and came slamming down, hard enough to knock
Jerry out, laying in a bloodied and bruised
mess.
Looking down at him, SCP-661 sneered, and
went back into his house, slamming the door
behind him.
Jerry wasn’t the only one whose attention
had been caught by the advertisements starring
this particularly rude man.
They had also garnered the scrutiny of the
SCP Foundation, who had placed this individual
– later known by the designation SCP-661
– under surveillance.
For a while, they had kept a close eye on
him, monitoring his day-to-day activity.
To the untrained eye, he was just an ordinary
– if a little overweight – man working
as an advertising and marketing agent.
He’d regularly star in TV and radio ads,
boasting the wild assertion that he could
easily convince anyone alive to do anything
he told them.
Now, sure, arrogance is hardly a purely anomalous
trait.
But what the Foundation soon realized was,
that claim was right.
Testing quickly revealed that SCP-661’s
voice possessed some kind of hypnotic or mesmeric
influence.
Simply by speaking, he could manipulate other
people into doing what he asked them to do,
or wanting what he told them they wanted.
Naturally, working in marketing, this made
him a salesman almost too good to be true,
just as long as someone could understand the
commands and suggestions he made.
Anyone exposed to his voice would feel a prolonged
sense of compulsion.
It began as a weak feeling at first, just
lingering in the back of a person’s mind
like a post-hypnotic suggestion; a thought
implanted by somebody else, that the subject
doesn’t act on until later.
The effect would normally last for around
a week, or until a time when the subject was
presented with the means to actually get what
SCP-661 had convinced them they wanted; say,
for example, a physical product like a food
processor.
Perhaps the worst part though, is that SCP-661
seems to have been aware of his anomalous
powers of influence for some time.
Although he claims otherwise, he’s shown
no problem in trying to use his manipulative
‘gift of the gab’ to convince the Foundation’s
personnel to release him from their custody,
where he is currently being held.
Lucky they bought themselves noise-canceling
headphones; those might be the only things
stopping this slimy salesman from getting
into their heads.
Now go and check out “SCP-738 THE DEVIL’S
DEAL” and “SCP-035 THE POSSESSIVE MASK”
for more anomalies with enticing offers for
unsuspecting humans, that can promise to fulfill
your deepest desires for a price…
except that price might not be worth paying!